what I tell young people is that I exist
because I got an education
there's no need even to have a college
degree at all
what's up believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so to help you on your
journey today we're gonna look at what
Michelle Obama and Elon Musk have to say
over is a traditional education orphan
also if you want to learn when Elon Musk
and other successful entrepreneurs have
to say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below there are times
when something is important enough
you've leave it enough that you do you
do it in spite of the fear okay let's
kick it off with Michelle Obama who says
education is essential for success what
I tell young people is that I exist
because I got an education right you
know what I am able to do you know any
positive impact that I've been able to
have it's because I came to this and the
other jobs that I've had with a solid
foundation and an education right and
what I noticed that you know education
isn't as cool as it should be you know I
mean we're not talking about it enough
and we're not encouraging kids to
understand that if they want to succeed
in life they really should be pursuing
completing their education whether
that's a four-year university or a
two-year Community College or getting
some kind of training that's just
essential and my parents didn't go to
college but I understood the value in
investing in that education so to reach
higher we want to start that drumbeat
and we want to have everybody in all
walks of life you know telling our kids
that an education is absolutely
essential and then we have to provide
them with the resources that they need
to actually get in and get through see
when Barack came in office one of the
very first things he did was to set what
he calls a North Star goal for the
entire country that by the year 2020
the year that all of you will be
graduating from college
that this country will have the highest
proportion of college graduates in the
world now Barack set this goal because
as a generation ago we were number one
in college graduates but over the past
couple of decades this country has
slipped all the way to 12th we've
slipped and that's unacceptable and
we've got a lot of work to do to turn
that around and get back on top but
Barack didn't just set that goal because
it's good for our country he did it
because he knows how important higher
education is to all of you as
individuals because when a year 2020
rolls around nearly 2/3 of all jobs in
this country are going to require some
form of training beyond high school
now that means whether it's a vocational
program Community College a four-year
university
you all are going to need some form of
higher education in order to build the
kind of lives that you want for
yourselves good careers to be able to
provide for your families now over to
Elan musk who says you don't need a
degree to be successful there's no need
even to have a college degree at all
we've been high schools are they the I
mean if somebody graduated from a great
university that maybe in Indy that may
be an indication that they will be
capable of great things but it's not
necessarily the case you know if you
look at say people like Bill Gates for
Larry Ellison Steve Jobs these guys
didn't graduate from college but if you
had a chance to hire them of course that
would be a good idea so you know just
really looking just for evidence of
exceptional ability and if there's a
track record of exceptional achievement
then it's likely that that will continue
into the future now I've got two really
special bonus clips from Michelle Obama
and Elon Musk on the importance of
reading and writing as well as taking
risks that I think
gonna really enjoy but before that I
want to know what are your thoughts who
do you agree with is a traditional
education worth it or not let me know
put your thoughts in the comments below
read write read read if the president
were here one of his greatest strengths
is reading that's one of the reasons why
he's a good communicator why he's such a
good writer he's a voracious reader so
we're trying to get our girls no matter
what to just be to love reading and to
challenge themselves with what they read
and not just read the gossip books but
to push themselves beyond and do things
that maybe they wouldn't do so I would
encourage you all to to read read read
just keep reading and writing is another
skill it's practice it's practice the
more you write the better you get drafts
our kids are learning the first draft
means nothing you're gonna do seven ten
drafts that's writing it's not failure
it's not not the teacher not liking you
because it's all marked up in red when
you get to be a good writer you mark
your own stuff in red and you rewrite
and you rewrite and you rewrite that's
what writing is and if you come out with
those skills and then you're confident
and you can articulate and you can stand
up straight and look anybody in the eye
and say this is who I am it's a pleasure
to meet you that's one of the things we
try to do with our mentoring program
with young girls my message to them is
if you can walk into the White House and
meet the first lady and say my name is
how are you and look me in the eye then
there's nothing you can't do that's why
it's important if you guys walked here
are sitting here in front of all these
people standing tall asking questions
using your voice you have to practice
that these arenas just show up again and
again and then you just get used to it
the nerves go away and you start
relaxing into your own abilities but
it's practice one of the most difficult
choices I have ever faced in life was
was in 2008 and I think I had
pick up maybe thirty million dollars
left thirty or forty one dollars left in
2008 I had two choices I could put it
all into one company and then the other
company would definitely die or split it
between the two companies and but if I
split it between two companies then both
might die and it would you put your
blood sweat and tears into creating
something a bully something it's like a
child
and so it's like which one am I gonna
let one starve to death I can bring
myself to do it surprised I split the
money between two what should I lay
thank goodness they both came through
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that that people need
passion and not one drop of most
self-worth depends on your it's supposed
to mean if you guys liked this video I
highly recommend checking out the one we
did of Warren Buffett and Barack Obama
talking about is an expensive education
worth it the link is right next to me
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
there's all kinds of information
available now with the internet it's so
much you know easier than it was then so